Butler on Irving this should be a nice
matchup to watch Irving with the
left-handed Scoob got it to go and then
he's got Butler plays him as well as you
can see he's right on top of them but
then that scoop left hand off the glass
we've gotten so used to seeing those
marvelous shots
Tyson wasn't waiting for it they didn't
write up that way but they'll take it
Brad Stevens has drawn up some really
slick blades I'm not sure he's gonna
take credit for that one the old off the
back to Kyrie one it's the glass
beautiful collected three points up to
this lowly strong to the basket
[Applause]
his back plays the blessed beautiful
play defense knee buckler with doggett
defense on Irving Kyrie kept his dribble
alive tough shot
now watch this shot watch as he gets
down in here he doesn't have anything
but now I'm gonna go right up with a
little fade not a great blame what a
touch you be now it's he's so smooth
never herky-jerky never in a rush and
that was great defense two-point game
[Music]
Irving for three yes
on the clock they got to shoot it let it
force to throw one up badly who could
walk out here Irving for three
today